and finally new rules since President
Obama is constantly being accused of
going on an apology tour he should just
go on one for two reasons it will drive
Republicans nuts especially if he wears
the turban and more importantly to a
world that has been trembling over the
prospect of us electing Donald Trump it
would be a great way to send the message
America we're back on our meds
so it's true the president is coming to
the last six months of his term which
after seven and a half years in office
must seem like those final few months of
high school remember that when you got
senioritis one of those rare intervals
in life when but I always wanted to
meets up with why the hell not and as
president that means doing some things
just for fun now that it's the end like
I don't know legalized pot put Beyonce
on the nickel
invite RuPaul to take a transgender leak
in the Rose Garden
did I mention legalized pot or at least
move it to the schedule move it off the
Schedule one drug list and move it on to
the you can buy it at Costco drugless or
do something really crazy and come on
this show
you
and then as your final act go on that
apology world tour why not our
government is already apologized
internally for Indian genocide to
victims of Japanese internment and the
Tuskegee experiments and of course for
the slave trade that horrible period
when it was legal to trade a black man
for another black man without a
first-round draft choice
go ahead give the white people
permission to laugh the black folks are
laughing you will laughing yeah yeah
a dozen presidents were slaveholders and
Thomas Jefferson wasn't just holding
them Oh America did some bad [ __ ] for
much of our history America acted like a
nasty drunk it's true
and now we should do what AAA tells
recovering drunks they should do make a
list of people you hurt and go around
and apologize to them cuz drunks get
drunk and do drunk ass things Robert
Downey jr. got so high he fell asleep in
the wrong house
no Gibson called a cop sugar tits
Britney Spears shaved her head David
Hasselhoff remember starred in Baywatch
there's no K terrible stuff but going
around
but going around and apologizing does
help so isn't it time America was at
least as enlightened as Earl remember my
name is Earl well my name is Sam and
first on my apology list is Vietnam
sorry Vietnam America wanted to fight
communism in the 60s but fighting it
over here might have made a mess so we
used your country sorry and sorry Mexico
for taking half your country just
because we could and a big sorry to Iraq
our eternal drunken booty call when we
invaded you knew it wasn't really you we
were mad at we were pretty badly hooked
on oil at the time and it made us do
some crazy things sorry and sorry to all
the countries where we toppled the
government and installed some stooge
Guatemala the Congo Iran the Dominican
Republic Brazil Chile not to mention all
the places where we supported dictators
because well we were afraid of her own
feelings and Stalin I wish there was
some way we could make it up to you is
there someone we could bomb
oh no no no what am I saying bombing
that's the oldest look Trump's campaign
that's the last dying gasp of the old
America America's inner [ __ ] the
macho screaming man baby but we're not
that guy anymore we elected a thoughtful
black president and now a woman we've
come a long way if you don't believe me
just remember this
LBJ used to [ __ ] with the door open
Obama has to go outside just to smoke